Ahmed arag spends his days in the
support man in Istanbul the 29 year old
hasn't been able to work since he fell
and endured his wrist two years ago
he needs surgery but can't afford it and
his landlord wants to increase the rent
Ahmed like many other Syrian refugees is
struggling as a Turkish economy awakens
I'm very frustrated I can't go to
another country I can't get treated here
and I can't return to Aleppo to see my
family I can't enjoy simple things in
life like other people my age here I'm a
stranger the worst thing is that I'm
young but can't work I have to sit at
home psychologically it's very upsetting
once hailed as a success story among
emerging economies trickier's inflation
exceeded 85 percent this year coupled
with Rising nationalism ahead of an
election in mid-2023 it has sparked the
backlash against Syrian refugees the
opposition has promised to send them
back most syrians we have approached in
Istanbul do not want to be interviewed
on camera because they're afraid of
being deported despite deteriorating
economic conditions and true care they
don't want to return home because
because they say a feature in Syria
doesn't hold much promise Walid ottuman
is an exception he spent eight years in
Turkey working all jobs that paid poorly
in 2020 he moved back to azalez to
realize his dream of going College even
though the diplomas are not
International recognized now while it
works for a local media organization my
friends told me not to return to Syria
and start over they said I wouldn't be
able to improve myself but here I am any
achievement in my country is better than
in another country this is more valuable
to me I hope all those syrians in Turkey
can return home to better conditions one
day Syria's opposition-held areas are
also affected by the inflation across
the border as they use the Turkish
currency we are trying to make basic
food items available but we make only a
small profit because of the changing
prices in a year the Turkish lira has
lost 40 percent of its value against the
US dollar and inflation is expected to
remain high in 2023 despite government
promises to reduce it leaving syrians
whether they live as refugees in turkey
or have returned home to opposition-held
areas with limited opportunities
Al Jazeera Istanbul